the un security council otherwise known
as the we
won world war ii club its five permanent
members are supposed to act as arbiters
for international disputes
and as a result of their status of great
clout in international affairs
but this raises a question who picked
them who decided who got a permanent
seat and who didn't
well to begin after world war ii the
world was in a bit of a mess
global powers were diminished empires
were crumbling and a new conflict was
beginning to take shape
the victorious powers of the war were
hoping to never repeat the same mistakes
again
and to do this they would create a board
of international great powers to discuss
arbitrate and vote on resolutions to
conflicts between countries before they
became wars
this board was to be the un security
council and unlike the failed league of
nations before it the people who came up
with the idea were on board this time
so in early 1945 the original plan for
the new security council was that it
would only have four members
they were the usa the ussr the united
kingdom and the republic of china
and it won't surprise you that those
members largely picked themselves
and whose participation in the new
united nations were necessary if it was
ever going to work
now for the us and china this
arrangement worked fine but for the ussr
and for britain there were some issues
that needed to be worked out
for the ussr they saw the new council as
being dominated by the us and its allies
and saw it as an anti-communist farce
they wanted another nation on the
council that would say no to the us
otherwise there was little point in any
of it and in response the us did several
things to alleviate the ussr's concerns
as a compromise on membership the us
offered to appoint brazil as the fifth
member which the ussr refused to agree
to because again they saw them as being
too closely aligned with the west
also brazil didn't want to join so it
was a moot point
as for britain it had several issues
with the current makeup of the security
council
its main problem was that as western
europe's only member of the council it
looked like its defense would be
britain's responsibility which britain
did not want because one
that sounded expensive and two british
political and public opinion of europe
at that point was largely that it was
something that dragged them into wars
and as such churchill pushed for a fifth
member france
the reason was that france wanted a
major voice in international relations
and would happily do the things that
britain didn't feel like the ussr agreed
with this pick as well since france was
one nation happy to say no to the united
states
and with that france was in and the five
permanent members of the un security
council were picked and after this there
were only two changes to the council's
members
the first was in 1971 when the u.n voted
for the people's republic of china to
become the officially recognized china
because let's be real the civil war was
over by that point and the communist
government wasn't going anywhere
the second time was in 1991 when the
ussr
entered a phase of no longer existing
and as such russia took up the ussr's
former place thus giving us the modern
permanent membership of the un security
council
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker the
pastry section marvin cassow rob
waterhouse danny maloney
mo aaron the white james castaneda
jordan longley marcus asner jerry lamdin
gustav swan rasheed ali
colin carson copper tone izzy david
silverman spinning three plates
winston k wood spencer lightfoot maggie
paxkowski
matthew shipley anthony beckett
fortunate calf robert wetzel lexy
schwinn and skye chappelle